yeah i mean it's so fascinating to me
that
corporate
media outlets and the employees who work
for them
love incessantly to talk about the
dangers of fake news and disinformation
and they love to lament the fact that
people now turn away from them and no
longer believe them and believe these
sources of information that they regard
as inferior to them or less reliable
than they are
and in the course of lamenting this
pathology which is a genuine problem
you need
a society if it's going to be healthy
democracy it's going to be healthy to
have
sources of information that
most people in the society even if they
have different ideologies can more or
less trust to tell them what's going on
in the world and if you lose that you
lose a really important stabilizing
force an ability for people to even have
shared perceptions of
the facts and reality
in all the discussions about how that's
happening and how bad it is
they almost never stop and ask the
question why has that happened
because the answer is
they play a central role
in why people have lost faith and trust
in those institutions
of journalism that have long been
regarded as legitimate by most people
they were the ones who sold the country
the lies that led to the invasion of
iraq
they were the ones who glorified the
people who brought us the 2008 financial
crisis from which people continue to
suffer to this very day and people are
not dumb they understood they saw for
themselves that the media was willing to
do and say anything to stop donald trump
and once you have this series of
episodes that justifiably and validly
cause a huge portion of the population
to no longer place their faith and trust
in established corporate media
institutions
of course they're going to start looking
elsewhere
for their news
and i do regard that as genuinely tragic
even though i believe the people who are
doing that are
acting appropriately i also don't trust
those institutions i regard it though
as as damaging because i do think a
healthy society needs
a kind of group of institutions you can
rely on and trust
and
part of my project
is not to try and destroy these
institutions but to try and rebuild
faith and trust in journalism by showing
that it can still be done
in a way that it can inspire confidence
among people who have differing
religious values political beliefs
ideologies and the like
and glenn what would you say to those
people who go look here's a reality the
media have always been lying to us
they've always been trying to pull the
wool over our eyes it's just now in 2016
and the age of the internet we are able
to see it for ourselves
there's definitely validity to that
argument um you know i
as you know you probably know before i
became a journalist i was working as a
lawyer
a constitutional lawyer and and i
started writing about politics at the
end of 2005. i just created a kind of
free blog
on what was called blogspot at the time
this free
blogging
platform
from google
in large part because i was looking at
the the
developments in the the wake of 9 11 and
the war on terror
and felt that the media was not only
ignoring really crucial
assaults on civil liberties but often
was lying about what was taking place
and the more i looked you know it was
the first time i paid attention as a
full-time job to politics and journalism
as opposed to law
the more i began realizing that this has
been a long standing problem throughout
the cold war
the cia partnered with
all of the major corporate institutions
media institutions in the united states
to disseminate propaganda they would
engineer coups and they would have time
magazine or the new york times call it
you know a popular revolution or a you
know blow against tyranny um
conversely when they had democratically
elected leaders they didn't like they
would have those media outlets call them
tyrants
and then hail the replacements who were
anointed by the us with no votes as
protectors of democracy so this
closeness between
the security state and large standing
corporate media outlets
has been going on again since the
security state was created at the end of
world war ii
and as i said that's the reason why
it wasn't
right-wing
media outlets that helped the bush
administration
sell the country on the iraq war it was
the liberal outlets like the new york
times
and the new yorker and the atlantic and
nbc news because those institutions
despite being more liberal on cultural
issues
were completely inextricably linked with
and deferential to
the government and that created all
kinds of deceit and propaganda so it
isn't that it's a new problem
at all i've been writing about it long
before anyone dreamed that donald trump
could be president obviously many other
people before me were doing the same
i think that what happened in the trump
administration is that all of that went
on to steroids
um you know at the very least even
though the media often propagandized on
questions of safe foreign policy and
barely ever questioned the security
state when it came to the kind of
day-to-day trivial warfare between the
two primary political parties the
republicans and democrats they would at
least make an effort
to have a pretense of objectivity
between the two parties not to favor one
or the other and that i think is more
than anything what
that that one kind of notion of fairness
that they were clinging to
ultimately even that got destroyed so
they just became open propaganda arms of
the democratic party
and engaged in open warfare against the
republican party all in the name of
stopping donald trump and and i think
that is what took that's what took what
was already clearly a systemic problem
but made it
a much much greater problem and a more
visible problem than ever before
so glenn what about now though because
look they got what they wanted the joe
biden is president the the democrats are
you know free to do almost whatever they
want uh you know the kids the kids are
still in cages but they don't have to
cover it and and all of that they're not
cages anymore they're detention
facilities that's correct of course they
are uh
and and so why are their brains still
broken they got trump out why can't they
just relax and start reporting the truth
now
well for one thing
if you look at
what has happened to them a lot of
people forget that before trump came
down that golden escalator with melania
in 2015 and now said he was running for
president
most of these media outlets were on the
verge of complete financial ruin
you can go back and find for example in
articles in 2014 and 2015 that msnbc was
on the verge of firing its entire
prime time lineup with the exception of
racial matter because nobody was
watching those shows and the new york
times
people really doubted whether they were
going to actually be able to have a
sustainable financial model
trump saved
almost the entire media industry
single-handedly ratings went through the
roof
um
enormous numbers of books were sold
people got very rich off
you know activism and warnings over
donald trump the aclu was laying off its
entire workforce basically in the obama
years no one wanted the aclu suing obama
on the grounds they was acting
unconstitutionally but then soon as you
know they position themselves as the
primary opponent to trump they they're
drowning in money
so they don't want he's a cash cow so
they don't want to you know go back to
just talking no one wants to hear about
joe biden
and that's why their audience is
disappearing
and
it's disappearing very quickly so
they're just desperate you know trying
to kind of pump life into this corpse
that is the trump presidency
but people know he's gone and so it's
not working
it is true that even though trump is no
longer in power there is his movement
that still has some degree of influence
i mean there's members of congress in
the senate who still espouses ideology
one of them is going to be the
republican nominee almost certainly in
2024 if trump himself as they're hoping
and praying on their knees on a daily
basis
runs again himself in 2024
so part of it is
just the profit model they need the
villain the scary monster right it's
like um you know if you have the game of
thrones you can't kill off cersei the
queen because who are you going to hate
and care about and be angry towards
that's kind of what trump is for
these media so they need to kind of prop
them up and keep them alive and and
convince themselves that the threat is
still there
but also i think some of them again do
genuinely believe that there's this
fascist movement lurking in the united
states ready to take over at any moment
and the hysteria and mania and paranoia
and delusions and psychological and
anxiety disorders that govern their
brains
and have since 2016
really haven't gone anywhere and so you
listen to them and it does sound like
they think it's 2018 in part because
they want it to be
and need it to be but also in part
because they still believe that it
really is
[Music]